Estados Unidos está de vuelta en la
lucha climática eso es lo que quiso
decir vaiden en la Cup 27 por eso no
solo se disculpó de que su país se haya
retirado del acuerdo de París sino que
aumentó varias de sus promesas por
ejemplo ya no habla de reducir en un 30%
los gases de metano 2030 como se
prometió en la con 26 sino que aspira a
que Estados Unidos los reduzcan un
87%, y duplicó a 100 millones de dólares
el dinero que Estados Unidos va a
destinar al fondo de adaptación Pero
adaptarse no es lo mismo que reconocer
los daños y las pérdidas que han
padecido los más vulnerables por la
crisis climática y al respecto vaiden no
dijo ni una sola palabra de lo que
exigen Las Naciones menos
industrializadas de crear un fondo para
esto una idea que Estados Unidos ya
hundió en la copa 26 qué más pasó hoy
Marina Pues es que hoy el tema de la
agenda oficial era la descarbonización
que es básicamente alejarse de
combustibles fósiles como el carbón o el
petróleo la jornada empezó con la
publicación de un informe en el que
decía que en 2022 estaríamos emitiendo
un 1% más de emisiones contaminantes que
el año pasado algo fatal para la lucha
en la crisis climática y que haría que
podríamos alcanzar la temperatura de
calentamiento del grado y medio en 2030
cuando lo que se acordó en París era que
no se alcanzará hasta el 2100 un anuncio
a destacar un grupo de 45 países que
representan más de la mitad del producto
interno bruto global se han lanzado 25
acciones prioritarias para descarbonizar
cinco sectores acciones que deberían
implementarse antes de la cop 28
recordemos que esta es la Cup de la
implementación una con 28 que se
celebrará en emiratos árabes Unidos país
que junto con Estados Unidos y con otros
ha sido otorgado con el premio del día
del fósil del día por no alejarse de
estos combustibles contaminantes